THE LOA
VARLAMOV GETS HIS WITS ABOUT CH.
>> Butch: FIRST THERE WAS A AND
NOTHING THERE.
OPENS IT UP FOR P P
VARLAMOV AND STOPS ANOTHER LIPN
DOBSON!
AGAIN.
A VARLAMOV.
>> Butch: LOOKED LIKE A TRIP
THERE, DIDN'TT CAN SEE HE HASN'
IT'S A TIE HOCKEY GAME.
THATL TAKE IT.
LEE FLYING THEND THE GOAL.
AND THE FOR
THE CANUCKS AND THERE'S A COUGH.
HUGHES GETS THE FIRST PELECH
AND PULOCK AND THROW IT OVER AN.
>> Brendan: OFF
LET'S HOPE UP.P.
IF GAME.
HE'S
GARIN THEY SCORE.
AND THE CANUCKS HAVE COME B GOO
BO WHO ARE VS LEAVES THE HORVAT
THAT BATTLE ALONG T T IT!
LOOSE TO THE BOARD.
OH,Y
ONE, 8:08 TO PLAY.
BROCK NELSON A COUPLE THERE.
NELSON CAN.
PARISE TRIED TO TAP IT
THE GOOD SOLID FORE-CHECKING.
GO TO THE NET AND YOU CAN SEE T
NET.